ya hemos visto cómo escribir expresiones
de equilibrio y bueno si tenemos por
aquí un ácido cualquiera que le va a
donar un protón a h2o
entonces h2o se va a convertir en h tres
o más y nuestro ácido se va a convertir
en la base conjugada que es pues a menos
nuclear y por aquí tenemos nuestra
expresión de equilibrio y la constante
de ionización ácida que a que ya hemos
visto que si se trata de un ácido débil
acá
va a ser menor que 1 entonces por aquí
tenemos 3 ácidos débiles el ácido
fluorhídrico ácido acético y metanol y
por acá tenemos los valores que de cada
uno de estos ácidos débiles y como
podemos observar el ácido fluorhídrico
tiene el valor de acá a más grande
porque hay aunque todos estos sean
nacidos débiles de todas formas el ácido
fluorhídrico tiene un valor de
a mayor que el del ácido acético y
entonces el ácido fluorhídrico es un
ácido más fuerte que el ácido acético y
el ácido acético es un ácido más fuerte
que el metanol pero de todas formas
todos estos ácidos siguen siendo ácidos
débiles sobre todo en comparación con
los ácidos fuertes pero bueno ahora
vamos a hablar de la constante de acá a
que es definida como menos logaritmo
base 10 de acá y entonces por ejemplo si
quisiéramos saber cuál es el pk
del metanol lo único que tenemos que
hacer es poner para acá a igual a menos
logaritmo base de 10 y aquí sustituir
acá
por el valor de acá del metanol o sea
2.9 por 10 a la menos 16 2.9
10 - 16 aunque vamos a sacar la super
calculadora
tenemos menos logaritmo base de 10 de
2.9 por 10 a la menos 16 eso nos da
aproximadamente
15.54 así es que el p k a del metanol es
15.54 y bueno podríamos hacer aquí otra
columna que nos dijera los valores de p
k a de cada uno de estos ácidos y el
valor pk
del metanol ya lo calculamos es 15.54 si
hiciéramos estos mismos cálculos pero
ahora para el ácido acético obtendríamos
un valor de 4.74 y de la misma forma si
hacemos estos cálculos para el ácido
fluorhídrico obtendríamos un valor de
3.46
y ahora nos podemos poner a observar
esta tabla y podemos observar que estos
ácidos van creciendo del ácido más débil
al ácido más fuerte de estos tres ok el
ácido clorhídrico es el ácido más fuerte
de estos ácidos débiles entonces tienen
un valor de caja más grande sin embargo
el valor de pk
aquí es el más chico de estos valores ok
entonces entre más chico sea tu valor pk
más fuerte es tu ácido 3.46 es más chico
que 4.74 y eso lo que nos dice es que el
ácido fluorhídrico es un ácido más
fuerte que el ácido acético